salut c'est monsieur greu énorme soirée
ce soir puisque au pot a officialisé
d'une son arrivée en france ça on savait
depuis un petit moment mais surtout à
réaliser la présentation de son nouveau
flagship le phénix ça faisait quatre ans
on attendait l'arrivée d'un nouveau
petit chai au pot voici l'arrivée du
finepix plutôt surprenant sur plusieurs
aspects il ya des choses qui me
paraissent en tout cas vraiment très
intéressants d'autres touchant aux plus
sceptiques
en tout cas ce smartphone doit vraiment
plus et les codes vallée de plus loin
comme l'a fait vivo avec son ex quelques
jours juste avant ça je vous en parlais
et on y va
propos c'est la marque numéro 4 en
termes de ventes de smartphones dans le
monde entier et numéro deux en chine au
pot arrive en europe
il commence par la france l'espagne
l'italie et lumière de haut pour yb en
europe et il commence pas la france
l'italie l'espagne et les pays-bas et va
ensuite développé petit à petit sur
l'ensemble de l'europe
alors on attendait depuis quelques temps
la présentation de ce finding c'est
vraiment un smartphone très attendue
parce que on sait que pau comme d'autres
constructeurs chinois et notamment vivo
savent bousculer les codes sa composé
des nouvelles technologies vraiment
intéressante qu'on trouve pas partout
qui d'ailleurs ton coup là est vraiment
purement inédite et risque vraiment de
changer un petit peu la donne en terme
de fabrication de smartphones parce que
ce qu'on voit que ce finepix est un
petit peu ce qu'on a vu avec le niveau
n'est que c'est pas très longtemps c'est
à dire un smartphone avec un écran qui
occupe quasiment la totalité la race
abandon car 90% de la face avant la
différence vous allez voir avec le
vivonne ex section le nex vous avez la
caméra de cette fille qui sort et au dos
vous avez un doute un peu plus classique
avec vos caméras
sur celui-ci vous avez absolument aucune
caméra bien évidemment rien à l'avant
par contre est derrière pour coup vous
avez n'ont plus aucune caméra vous avez
un tiroir qui s'ouvre dès lors une
sollicité l'appareil photo ou alors
lorsque vous avez besoin de le
déverrouiller vous appuyer pour les
druides ça sort ça vous reconnaissent à
se referme
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt astucieux et
sa propose vraiment une vraie
alternative aux vives onex ça propose
aussi une alternative aux fesses heidi
d'apple parce que pour coup on a un vrai
scan en trois dimensions votre visage et
avec toutes les possibilités qui vont
découler derrière les haies modja nuit
là vous en parler d'ici quelques
instants
on va vraiment que le monde des
smartphones est vraiment en train de
continuer à évoluer il ya eu l'encoche
qui a paru en fin d'année dernière
l'encoche qui tend à faire des petits
cette année est la preuve qu elle
pourrait carrément disparaître avoir six
autres constructeurs s'y mettent
est ce que apple va prendre le pas et va
retirer son nom qu est-ce qui vont se
positionner sur ce système est ce que
samsung pas continuer à faire des écrans
toujours plus grands et utilisez
également ce même système
c'est des choses qui reste à voir à
tendance pour est vraiment très très
prometteur
c'est vraiment de pas encore de
nouvelles techno et surtout des
constructeurs n'hésitent pas à aller
plus loin et à bouscule un peu les codes
la première chose à retenir sur ce
produit c'est vraiment son design on a
un écran qui occupent 80
bien que 8% de la face avant un écran
légèrement incurvé sur les côtés vous
avez des bords arrondis autour du
smartphone un écran oled de 6 4 pouces
qui pour que quand on regarde en vidéo
est vraiment magnifique
c'est un design qui est super bien et
chez il ya un vrai bord à bord vous avez
une légère légère petite bande d'une
rampe a vraiment pas énorme décembre
pour les questions technologiques
il faut bien évidemment pour un moment
branché l'écran donc probablement pour
ça car cette petite partie sur le banc
mais pour le coup ça faut absolument
aucun problème au dos il est disponible
en deux couleurs vous avez le board
rouge et le glacier bleus je passe un
peu les couleurs qu'ils sont sympas qui
ont été bien présenté pour vraiment
aller directement sur le point le plus
intéressant c'est à dire ce tiroir qui
souffre et qui se ferme qui va des
volets l'avant une caméra 25 méga pixels
avec le système aux fesses c'est le
faith heidi d'apple c'est un équivalent
qui va nous faire un scan un mapping en
trois dimensions votre visage par une
projection d'infrarouge ce qui fait que
vous pourrez même le déverrouiller dans
noir et ça c'est plutôt un point très
intéressant surtout que vous n'êtes
absolument aucun capteur 1 du tout mise
à part tape un code la banque ou revenir
vraiment un peu à la préhistoire du
smartphone mais avec ce système on n'a
pas à s'inquiéter
ce qui est très intéressant que le
système à un tiroir ce qu'ils annoncent
une ouverture fermeture en 0.5 secondes
quelque chose d' extrêmement rapide
alors quand j'ai regardé la présentation
je me suis posé la question on se dit
bon d'accord c'est bien ça souffle ça va
ça remet tout le temps dehors vous
prenez le téléphone vous voulez
débrouiller sa source à se faire vous
leur posez vous reprenez sa source à ce
terme
ça souffle sa star et qui ment en
permanence donc le système intéresse
plutôt fiable ce qu'annoncé au pot c'est
qu'elle déteste qui a été fait jusqu'à
300 milles ouverture/fermeture ce qui
selon eux dans l'utilisation du
smartphone de cinq ans bon on sait quand
même générale le taux de renouvellement
d'un smartphone c'est plutôt 18 mois 5
ans de l'homme n'a rien petit peu en fin
de course ça pose toujours un petit peu
question dès lors j'ai une partie
mécanique
d'autant plus que là c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est au coeur du
système permet de déverrouiller et
tableaux photos ça c'est un petit peu le
point par des interrogations alors
j'imagine que sur un smartphone très
haut de gamme comme vient de faire aux
poux sur ce coup là sont sans leurs
coûts sur leurs copies aps et non pas de
doute néanmoins sa part guen a eu dix
ans par rapport aux techniques ont
aujourd'hui d'avoir un truc qui va
s'ouvrir pack tacle qui va se fermer à
chaque fois dès lors qu'on abandonne le
déverrouiller mais bon pourquoi pas des
données qui selon opposent sont
complètement sécurisé on a pas de risque
a priori de piratage de se faire voler
notre reconnaissance faciale s'arrêtera
également d'avoir des paiements
sécurisés
parce que dans une
si vous posez votre smartphone
directement grâce au nfc hop il vous
reconnaît et pat s'est payé avec un
petit sourire
ces caméras parlons-en comme je vous le
disais avant vous avez une caméra de 25
mégapixels à l'arrière vous avez une
double caméra 5 mégapixels 20 mégapixels
on a absolument pour l'instant aucune
information sur l'ouverture des
objectifs
néanmoins au pour nous assure permettra
de faire des photos complètement
optimisé notamment conditions de basse
luminosité
il faut savoir est derrière vous avez un
processeur qualcomm snapdragon 845
couplé à 8 gigas de ram un processeur
qui est vraiment optimisé pour
l'intelligence artificielle l'apprend
cours pour vraiment l'utiliser avec de
l'intelligence artificielle notamment
pour la photo avec de la reconnaissance
de scène
vous avez 21 scénario différent votre
appareil va pouvoir connaître de la
neige des personnes un paysage de
nourriture un chien chat que sais-je et
s'assure 21 scénario différent
maintenant voulons pas faire belles
photos vous avez également celle fille
et mode portrait trois dimensions avec
différentes possibilités d'éclairage
pour avoir des selfs y sont plus réussis
alors pas forcément pour les faits
évoqués mais on peut avoir différents
types d'éclairages un petit peu comme
effet studio qu'on peut retrouver chez
apple à partir d'un iphone 8
ces fameuses caméras avant avec le haut
'face à vous permettent d'avoir des mji
animer ce qu'ils appellent les eaux
moggi chez apple cdic ait quelque chose
chez opposés aux quelque chose donc là
ce sont les eaux moggi vous pourrez donc
faire des jolis sourires avec une tête
de charlie tête de chien de je ne sais
pas quoi
là ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
même beaucoup plus ouvert que
l'environnement d'apple donc vous allez
pouvoir envoyer des messages prendre des
photos avec est partagée on imagine sur
différents réseaux sociaux
ça ça reste effectivement avoir à tester
mais c'est une techno qui fonctionne
vraiment bien qu'ils aient assez
rigolote
autre point qui est vraiment intéressant
au niveau les caméras hier vous avez une
stabilisation optique donc pour vos
vidéos y avoir des photos qui ne bouge
pas ça va être vraiment top
alors bien évidemment vous allez avoir
du hdr on imagine qu y aura plein de
filton chose vous avez vraiment avoir un
appareil qui va être complètement
optimisé au niveau de l'eau est ce vous
avez
une surcouche color os 5.1 qui est basé
sur un android oreo 8.1 au pot un
partenariat fort avec google donc vous
allez pouvoir utiliser google assistant
d'autant plus que comme je vous êtes à
l'heure l'intelligence artificielle est
vraiment mise en avant
il ya vraiment un focus qui a été fait
sur l'optimisation vialatte et jean
certifie ciel c'est à dire l
intelligence artificielle qui a pouvoir
faire de la prédiction il à pouvoir en
quelque sorte si vous voulez deviner ce
que vous allez pouvoir faire c'est à
dire très chargé des applications avant
même que vous appuyez sur le bouton
ce qui fait que dès lors vous allez
appuyer sa va se charger en un fragment
de temps ça c'est plutôt intéressant
j'imagine que derrière il ya un espèce
de machine learning l'inter artificiel
va apprendre d'autres utilisations pour
optimiser des pré chargement tout soit
plus rapide et plus fluide ce qui
permettra de gagner forcément en temps
de chargement c'est une machine vous les
ayez un instinct dragon 845 8 gigas de
ram mais qui aussi proposé avec 256 giga
de stockage et vous avez leurs systèmes
de charge rapide qui s'appelle le voc
fast charge voulu mettre des cinq
minutes de charge vous pouvez passer
deux heures au téléphone ça c'est en
tout cas ce que nous a balancé au pot il
faut savoir qu'avec le bloc face chat
vous rechargez votre appareil en 1h30
peu une recharge complète et tout ça
avec une batterie de 3730 millan paire
eur je vous avais l'usb type c vous avez
un haut parleur mono vous devez avoir
probablement je suppose j'ai pas vu mais
je pense du bluetooth 5.0 ça paraît très
très logique du nfc forcément au delà de
ça au pot a annoncé un modèle je dirais
plutôt plus haut de gamme plus spécial
édition en partenariat avec lamborghini
c'est donc le phénix lamborghini special
edition vous avez un dos en fibre
carbone avec un effet 3d toujours plus
jolis modèles vous ai trouvé pour coup
un peu plus masculin et clou du
spectacle vous n'avez pas le voc fast
charge
vous avez le super bock fast charge qui
va encore plus vite ce qui fait que en
35 minutes
vous avez recharger l'intégralité de
votre smartphone je ne parle pas d'une
heure et demie avec le vote par chance
qui va déjà très vite là vous avez le
super bock fast sciages en 35 minutes
la machine est complètement chargé
incroyable et pour coup dans celui-là
vous avez une batterie de 3400
milliampères heures bon ça c'est bien
beau mais le prix qu'en est il du prix
parce que dark flammes sur des
techniques sont très hautes
am des choses qu'on n'a pas vu ailleurs
je vous parle effectivement de ce petit
tiroir qui s'ouvre et qui stagne on a
effectivement comme on disait sur la vie
von hexe tout petits tiroirs pour la
caméra de cette fille qui s'ouvre mais
pas du tout ce système là pas ce système
de reconnaissance en trois dimensions
pas du tout ce système vous avez un
grand tiroir qui s'ouvre pour la caméra
avant et la caméra arrière du court
terme de budget cela fait quand même un
appareil qui coûte 999 euros pour
l'édition normale
le finepix classique et si vous voulez
le modèle finepix lamborghini special
edition
ça vous coûtera 1699 euros
autant dire que globalement pas du tout
une bagatelle ce qui fait que ce pack dx
est plus cher que samsung galaxy s 9
plus moins cher que l'iphone 10 à voir
s'il va nous proposer apple d'ici
quelques mois
mais on va très clairement le
positionnement très haut de gamme en
terme de budget c'est quand même hyper
hyper hyper on vous attendez pas à
tarifs aussi élevés je me doutais
qu'avec toutes les nouvelles
technologiques ont d'ailleurs trouvé le
produit y aller quand même être pas
cadeau cadeaux je ne m'attendais pas à
un tarif de 1000 euros pour au pot pour
leur arrivée en france
mais après tout ça paraît assez logique
vu la fiche technique vu les innovations
vu la recherche-développement qu'ils
aient un tarif quand même qu'ils soient
assez élevé attendez quand même
d'internet un peu plus agressif pour
arriver son marché européen sous que ici
pour l'instant au pot reste quand même
malgré tout généralement un grand
inconnu donc arriver à 1000 euros alors
que la marque n'est pas trop connu même
ses techno sont super je sais pas si ça
va jouer vraiment en leur faveur
le temps nous le dira d'un produit qui
sera disponible très prochainement au
mois d'août de cette année on a un doute
on va aussi avoir un le galaxy note 9
qui devrait arriver et au mois de
septembre
la nouvelle gamme d'iphone 2018 donc là
il va passer plein de choses j'ai
malheureusement pas pu être présent
évènements dont j'ai pas pu prendre se
produire demain je vais essayer de
récupérer très prochainement pour tester
et vous dire directement ce que j'en
pense donc je vous invite à faire une
seule chose car deux choses déjà les
singes les pousse surtout vous abonner
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous seriez prêt à payer 999
euros pour acheter un phénix des
chauffe-eau et alors carrément 1699
euros pour le finepix lamborghini
special edition est ce que ça ça vous
paraît cohérent que c'est quelque chose
que vous pourriez faire est ce que vous
connaissez déjà au pot et est ce que
vous trouvez ce produit intéressant est
ce qu'il vous
mais est ce que vous le trouvez
séduisant est ce que l'idée du tiroir
vous botte est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une vraie belle avancée ou est ce
que vous trouvez qu au final c'est un
gadget permet d'avoir effectivement un
très grand écran mais un gadget qui
coûte quand même relativement cher vous
ne marquez tout son commentaire on
discute ensemble et puis on reste
qualité parce que vous allez voir ce
smartphone on va en reparler
il ya plein de choses qui arrivent plein
de surprises dont je vous dis à très
bientôt porter vous regarde vous rendre
à cannes
[Musique]